This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Radio, Francis. The handle or name you adopt should be one of a kind based on something special in your life. This is 20 Chabrogan, March 4, 1973. White brand land. All you nice people living in the middle of America, they're beautiful. Everything is beautiful. We're talking about radio, radio, meaning you do not see the picture.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。广播，弗朗西斯。你采用的代号或名字应该是独一无二的，基于你生活中一些特殊的事情。这是1973年3月4日的20号查布罗根。白色品牌土地。所有住在美国中部的好心人们，他们很漂亮。一切都很美。我们在谈论广播，广播意味着你看不到画面。
You hear the voice. Here's something called the box humana. Here's a human voice. The voice radio involves the audience, fire more than television, every year. This is WJK. One day in March 12, 1973. Thank you and here's some more in music. Take 20 now people. This is Big Jetter. I'm on a way to Canaan Land.
你听到声音。这里有一种叫做人类之盒（box humana）的东西。这里有人类的声音。广播之声比电视更能让听众参与进来，每年如此。这是 WJK。1973年3月12日的一天。谢谢你，这里还有更多的音乐。现在20号上。这是大杰特（Big Jetter）。我在去迦南之地的路上。
Here we go. Podcasting, we're like of a a better term has been good to me. But there's something about the transmission of radio signals that I love. For billions of years, the electromagnetic spectrum was populated only by radiation from natural objects. And then, all of a sudden, the air was filled with voices and codes and dots and dashes and music. My romance with Radio began decades ago, but one of the key stories that captured my imagination at the very beginning of my radio career was the shortwave numbers mystery.
我们开始吧。播客，如果换个更好的词来形容的话，一直对我不薄。但我就是热爱无线电信号的传输。在数十亿年的时间里，电磁波谱中只有来自自然物体的辐射。然后，突然之间，空中充满了声音、密码、点、划和音乐。我与广播的罗曼史始于几十年前，但在我广播生涯刚开始时，最吸引我想象力的关键故事之一就是短波数字谜团。
Produced by David Goren, the kitchen cistern's lost and found sound series. It's one of my favorite stories about one of my favorite subjects of all time, so I'm going to play it for you. The shortwave numbers mystery was first broadcast in May of 2000. Here's David Goren. The first time I heard a Spanish numbers lady, I was a kid, lying in bed, tuning around on my uncle's old shortwave radio. I was baffled by the solitary voice. She's still on the air, and even though I've heard her in one form or another since the early 70s, the sound of her voice continues to haunt me.
由大卫·戈伦（David Goren）制作，“厨房蓄水池的失物招领声音”系列。这是我最喜欢的关于我一直最喜欢的主题的故事之一，所以我打算放给你们听。短波数字谜团于2000年5月首次广播。这是大卫·戈伦。我第一次听到西班牙数字女郎的声音时，我还是个孩子，躺在床上，转动着我叔叔的旧短波收音机。我被这个孤零零的声音搞糊涂了。她还在广播，尽管我从70年代初就开始以各种形式听她的声音，但她的声音听起来仍然让我挥之不去。
Ever since I was 13, I've scoured the shortwave bands for exotic signals. It's hard not to stumble over a number station. When I first heard them, no one seemed to know anything about them. By the end of the 70s, they acquired a following. A hardquake group of listeners continued to obsessively tape and analyze these stations. Think of them catchy nicknames like the Boardman and Bulgarian Betty. You statement tracks the numbers for monitoring times, a journal for hardcore radio listeners. They're encrypted messages to somebody.
从13岁起，我就在短波频段中搜寻奇异的信号。很难不偶然发现一个数字电台。当我第一次听到它们时，似乎没有人知道它们是什么。到70年代末，它们有了一批追随者。一小群铁杆听众继续痴迷地录制和分析这些电台。给它们起了引人注目的绰号，比如博德曼（the Boardman）和保加利亚贝蒂（Bulgarian Betty）。你的声明追踪数字的监测时间，这是给铁杆广播听众的杂志。它们是发给某人的加密消息。
We think it's despised, we hope it's just despised, nothing more sinister than that. A number station is defined as any of several hundred shortwave radio broadcasters, all of which are using high-power big transmitters, large antennas, global coverage of the entire planet, which do nothing except broadcast meaningless strings of numbers. They never say why they're doing it, they never say who they are. My take on the numbers transmissions is that that the evil twin of a standard churwaeve station. They have announcers and programming of a sword. They even adhere to a vintage shortwave tradition, the interval signal.
我们认为这是被鄙视的，我们希望它只是被鄙视，没有比这更险恶的了。数字电台被定义为数百个短波广播电台中的任何一个，它们都使用大功率大发射机、大天线、覆盖整个星球的全球范围，除了广播毫无意义的数字串之外，什么都不做。他们从不说他们为什么要这么做，也从不说他们是谁。我对数字传输的看法是，它是标准短波电台的邪恶双胞胎。它们有某种播音员和节目。它们甚至坚持复古的短波传统——间隔信号。
This is a little diddy played a few minutes before the main broadcast to help the listener find and fine-tune the signal. Next comes the header. Green, nine, seven, one, five. the header. The header is followed usually by something that lets people know the header is over. The CIA likes to beep, other stations do other strange things. Then they usually go into the message, which is a series of number groups, four or five numbers. I'm revisiting myself as a lonely agent sitting in the basement in some urban area. I have no friends.
这是一首在主广播前几分钟播放的小曲子，帮助听众寻找并微调信号。接下来是标头。绿，九，七，一，五。标头。标头后面通常跟着一些让人们知道标头结束的东西。中情局喜欢发出蜂鸣声，其他电台则做其他奇怪的事情。然后他们通常进入消息，这是一系列数字组，四个或五个数字。我把自己想象成一个孤独的特工，坐在某个市区地下室里。我没有朋友。
I'm far from home. I'm far from my family. And this is my communication. This is my link back to my world. So I'm very carefully recording this message. Tell me something. I say again. I ask Bushneyer a leading academic cryptographer.
我远离家乡。我远离家人。这就是我的通讯。这是我连接回我的世界的纽带。所以我非常小心地记录这条消息。告诉我一些事。我再说一遍。我问领先的学术密码学家布什内尔（Bushneyer）。
Why an intelligence agency would communicate with an agent in the field in such an open way? It seems to be a relic of the Cold War. We always think of the radio as mass broadcast. You speak on the radio and everybody listens. This is an example of radio being used to talk to one particular person. You encrypt the message, which allows you to use this public broadcast medium to send a private message. That's really very pretty. The CIA does it, Russia does it, Cuba does it, the British do it, everybody does it. Hewstegman.
为什么情报机构会以如此公开的方式与前线特工沟通？这似乎是冷战的遗物。我们总是认为广播是大众广播。你在广播里说话，每个人都在听。这是利用广播与某个特定的人对话的一个例子。你加密消息，这允许你使用这个公共广播媒介来发送私密消息。这真的很漂亮。中情局这样做，俄罗斯这样做，古巴这样做，英国人这样做，每个人都这样做。休·斯特格曼（Hew Stegman）。
Okay evidence, that's a problem, there's never anything that hard. I've always assumed these are using a one-time pad or a variant, which are theoretically unbreakable given the assumptions of only having the cypher text or only having what's broadcast on the stations. A one-time pad has a page of random numbers, which is the key used to encrypt and then decrypt the message. The sender and recipient each have a copy. The pad is used once and then destroyed. It is pretty much untraceable. The operations have been compromised over and over again. People are captured, people change sides, people just get sloppy. Many many times they've seen the code pads, they've seen the receivers. The fact that the other side
好吧，证据，这是个问题，从来没有什么那么确凿的东西。我一直假设这些使用的是一次性密码本或其变体，鉴于只有密文或只有电台广播内容的假设，它们在理论上是不可破解的。一次性密码本有一页随机数字，这是用于加密然后解密消息的密钥。发送者和接收者各有一份。密码本使用一次后就被销毁。它几乎是不可追踪的。行动一次又一次地被泄露。人们被捕，人们叛变，人们只是变得马虎。很多很多次，他们看到了代码本，他们看到了接收器。事实是另一方
knows that this is how they do it does not give them any more access to the information. It's a perfect system in that respect. Some stations get jailed. presumably by rivals who pinpointed the transmitter site using sophisticated techniques. A numbers enthusiasm has to rely on intensive listening to pick up any clues. Most of what you hear in the United States does come from Cuba. The Cuban stuff started right after Castro got in and started getting tensions in that area. It has gone on since the engineering is sloppy, tape stop and the middle tapes are played backwards. They play Radio Havana by mistake, Radio Havana plays them by mistake.
知道这是他们做事的方式，并没有让他们获得更多信息的途径。在这方面，这是一个完美的系统。一些电台被捕获。据推测是由使用复杂技术的竞争对手精确定位了发射机站点。数字狂热者必须依靠大量倾听来捕捉任何线索。你在美国听到的大多数声音确实来自古巴。古巴的东西在卡斯特罗上台并开始在该地区产生紧张局势后就开始了。它一直在继续，工程很马虎，磁带停止，中间的磁带被倒着播放。他们错误地播放了哈瓦那电台，哈瓦那电台错误地播放了他们的。
You get the idea they're just barely on top of the situation, but they keep at it. There's another Spanish-numbers lady who is widely heard in North America. Some numbers monitors claim to have traced the signal to a government transmitter site in Warrantin, Virginia. They call her Cynthia, as it starts with a C and ends with IA. Havana Moon just came out of nowhere. He just started writing one day about the shortwave numbers, and his stuff was extremely provocative, and it seemed to come from straight inside.
你会觉得他们勉强掌握了局势，但他们一直在坚持。还有另一个在北美被广泛收听的西班牙数字女郎。一些数字监测员声称已将该信号追溯到弗吉尼亚州沃伦顿的政府发射机站点。他们叫她辛西亚（Cynthia），因为它以C开头，以IA结尾。哈瓦那月亮（Havana Moon）突然凭空出现。他有一天开始写关于短波数字的文章，他的东西极其挑衅，而且似乎直接来自内部。
The only thing he would ever say about himself was that he was a retired intelligence type, a real trench coat cloaked-and-dagger spook. There is some connection between the operations and the ranking, where we can have the I-LE, and maybe the defense and the run, and the run to the end, the I.O.D. and maybe the defense of the emergency. Havana Moon was a gentleman named William Godby.
他唯一愿意谈论自己的事情是，他是一个退休的情报人员，一个真正的穿着风衣、披着斗篷和匕首的间谍。行动和军衔之间存在某种联系，我们可以有I-LE，也许还有国防和奔跑，以及奔跑到最后，I.O.D.以及也许防御紧急情况。哈瓦那月亮是一个名叫威廉·戈德比（William Godby）的绅士。
He was a retired naval personnel, and he was just a very nice gentleman enough. Havana Moon, who died in 1996, found a co-conspirator in John Fulford, an ex-police intelligence officer with an interest in radio's dark side. During the late 1980s, they roamed around Florida with the radio direction finder. He confided in me that he suspected there was one possible two transmitter sites in South Florida. He had an idea where a couple of them were. We took some equipment out. I set the direction finder up. We took some bearings over a couple of weeks, where the bearing lines crossed,
他是一名退役的海军人员，而且他是一个非常好的绅士。于1996年去世的“哈瓦那月亮”在约翰·富尔德（John Fulford）那里找到了一个同谋，后者是一名对广播黑暗面感兴趣的前警察情报官。在20世纪80年代末，他们带着无线电测向仪在佛罗里达州四处游荡。他向我吐露，他怀疑南佛罗里达州有一个可能两个发射机站点。他知道其中几个在哪里。我们带了一些设备出去。我架设了测向仪。我们在几周内进行了一些方位测定，方位线相交的地方，
was right around a military transmitter site, located in one of the airports here in South Florida. We drove right to the airport, when the transmitters came on, the radio that we jumped out of our hands, of the signal was so loud. So we figured right there, we had it. During the day, the Navy sent standard traffic over this transmitter.
就在佛罗里达州南部这里的一个机场内的一个军事发射机站点附近。我们直接开车去了机场，当发射机启动时，我们手中的对讲机差点跳出我们的手，因为信号太大了。所以我们就在那里认为，我们找到了。白天，海军通过这个发射机发送标准流量。
Located at West Palm Beach International Airport, its frequency was just three kilohertz away from the numbers transmission. The antennas were being down into the Caribbean. Who sent the traffic? What happened? No idea. It is an unmanned site sent over a telephone line from the parts unknown. That will have no idea. Obviously, one of the intelligence agencies. My name is John R. Winston. I'm the assistant bureau chief of the enforcement bureau federal communications commission. We do not intend to discuss these stations if any exists at all and I'm not saying there are.
它位于西棕榈滩国际机场，其频率距离数字传输仅三千赫兹。天线正向下延伸到加勒比海。谁发送的流量？发生了什么？不知道。这是一个无人值守的站点，通过来自未知地点的电话线发送。对此完全没有头绪。很明显，是某个情报机构。我的名字是约翰·R·温斯顿（John R. Winston）。我是联邦通信委员会执法局的副局长。我们不打算讨论这些电台（如果它们确实存在的话，我并不是说有）。
If you're signed to say there are those that are transmitting in this country we know of innumerable ones outside of this country. Our only interest is if they are causing interference. We then work with the country of transmission to seek solution. Well, you can't hide a transmitter. Cryptographer Bruce Schneyer. Now, remember what a number station is doing. It's hiding the location of the recipient. The location of the transmitter is not necessarily a secret.
如果你签下来说有那些在这个国家发射的，我们知道这个国家之外有无数个。我们唯一的兴趣是它们是否造成干扰。然后我们与发射国合作寻求解决方案。好吧，你无法隐藏发射机。密码学家布鲁斯·施奈尔（Bruce Schneier）。现在，记住一个数字电台在做什么。它在隐藏接收者的位置。发射机的位置不一定是秘密。
The person who's receiving it is somewhere, and we don't know where. Every night in the wake in Europe you could hear these weird gongs, some like some sort of church bells out of the tomb. That was part of the Starr's stations. Simon Mason discovered the numbers in much the same way I did. By the mid-80s he'd begun to seriously document the European number seen from his home in Kingston upon hall in England. There's been this spy uncovered in my home city. He seriously documented the European number seen from his home in Kingston upon hall in England.
接收它的人在某处，而我们不知道在哪里。每天晚上在欧洲醒来时，你都能听到这些奇怪的锣声，有些像某种来自坟墓的教堂钟声。那是星之电台的一部分。西蒙·马森（Simon Mason）发现这些数字的方式和我差不多。到80年代中期，他开始认真记录他在英国赫尔河畔金斯顿的家中的欧洲数字场景。我的家乡发现了一个间谍。他认真记录了他在英国赫尔河畔金斯顿的家中的欧洲数字场景。
There has been this spy uncovered in my home city. I know what he was listening to when he was under the control of the Stasley, the East German secret place. The god knows what his wife and kids thought when he had his gongers coming out of his kitchen hot. Five months after the Berlin Wall fell, the concession went off the air forever. Bayern lagged a lot of the big players in the cold water there have gone now. And there's a lot of activity now in the Far East. The strangest one of the lot has got to be the one from Taiwan.
我的家乡发现了一个间谍。我知道他在东德秘密警察斯塔西的控制下在听什么。天知道当他的厨房里传出锣声时，他的妻子和孩子是怎么想的。柏林墙倒塌五个月后，特许经营权永远停止了广播。拜仁，冷战中的许多大玩家现在都走了。现在远东有很多活动。其中最奇怪的一定是来自台湾的那个。
Writer Hustegui. It's called Newstar Broadcasting, and it has this lady who they tell me even the net culture is way way to enthusiastic. And she's been computerized and she comes out of the machine. She says things like, good morning, please decode your message. This is all the Mandarin of course. She says things like, thank you very much for decoding today's message. I hope you have a nice day. I mean, she's being nice to the spies. You gotta love it. At this station is so over the top, it needs statement to think that the purpose is less
作家休斯特基（Hustegui）。它叫新星广播（Newstar Broadcasting），里面有一个女士，他们告诉我，连网络文化都对她热情过头了。她已经被计算机化了，她从机器里出来。她说诸如“早上好，请解码你的消息”之类的话。当然，这全是普通话。她说诸如“非常感谢您解码今天的消息。希望您度过美好的一天”之类的话。我的意思是，她对间谍很好。你不得不喜欢它。这个电台太夸张了，以至于需要声明来认为其目的较少
for transmitting secret messages than for spreading disinformation. Just this colossal diversion so that the mainland Chinese will think that Taiwan has put hundreds and hundreds of agents into that country, which they might or might not have done. I would say that's maybe why half these agencies do it this way. It makes two guys in a government office and some crummy building without water somewhere. Sound like you know they're on a level with the CIA. Everybody sounds the same on shortwave. Most monitors seem sure that the number stations are a part of international espionage,
为了传输秘密消息，而是为了散布虚假信息。这只是一种巨大的转移视线，以便中国大陆会认为台湾已经向该国派出了成百上千名特工，他们可能已经这样做了，也可能没有。我想说，这也许就是为什么这些机构中有一半会这样做。它让一个破烂建筑里没有水的政府办公室里的两个人，某个地方。听起来你知道他们和中情局处于同一水平。在短波上，每个人听起来都一样。大多数监测员似乎确信数字电台是国际间谍活动的一部分，
but some signals remain elusive. There are a few strange stations that almost admit, like the buzzer on F625 killer hits. Maybe just keeping this frequency up in case some sort of well disaster happens and then it can take over whether they're just a simple shortwave setup after all they, the sasselite's are being blown out of the sky. Just like a note padden paper left behind in case your computer crashes. I think it's just the biggest conceptual art project unintentionally or otherwise that anybody ever made that puts Christo and those guys to shame. It's planetary. I listen to shortwave these days with a bit of a pang. It's fading out
但有些信号仍然难以捉摸。有几个奇怪的电台几乎承认，比如F625千赫上的蜂鸣器。也许只是为了保持这个频率，以防发生某种灾难，然后它可以接管，无论它们是否只是一个简单的短波设置，毕竟，卫星正被炸出天空。就像留在后面以防你的电脑崩溃的记事本和纸一样。我认为这只是任何人做过的最大的概念艺术项目，无论是无意还是其他，这让克里斯托（Christo）和那些家伙相形见绌。它是行星级别的。我现在听短波时有点隐隐作痛。它正在消退，
regarded as archaic by many international broadcasters yet the number stations persist. Sometimes when I hear one, I write down some of the groups and wonder who the message is for and what it might say. Meet your contact. Blow up the bridge. Don't blow up the bridge. Maybe it's just keep listening. A tension on Seis Yette, Trace Yette Serro, the shortwave numbers mystery was produced
被许多国际广播公司视为过时，但数字电台依然存在。有时当我听到一个时，我会写下一些组，并想知道这条消息是给谁的，它可能在说些什么。与你的联系人见面。炸毁桥梁。不要炸毁桥梁。也许只是继续倾听。注意西斯·叶特（Seis Yette），特雷斯·叶特·塞罗（Trace Yette Serro），短波数字谜团是由
by David Goren in 2000. Special thanks to Hugh Stegman, Simon Mason, Chris Mullensky, Jonathan Marks, Tom Savart, a keen Fernandez of the Cognit project, and Carill Wheeler. It was produced for the Kitchen Sisters' Lost and Found Sound project on NPR in the year 2000. I caught up with David Goren in 2013 and asked him about what was going on with the number of stations today.
大卫·戈伦（David Goren）于2000年制作。特别感谢休·斯特格曼（Hugh Stegman）、西蒙·马森（Simon Mason）、克里斯·穆伦斯基（Chris Mullensky）、乔纳森·马克斯（Jonathan Marks）、汤姆·萨瓦特（Tom Savart）、认知项目的阿基恩·费尔南德斯（Akeen Fernandez）和卡里尔·惠勒（Carill Wheeler）。它是在2000年为NPR的厨房之声失物招领声音项目制作的。我在2013年采访了大卫·戈伦，问他关于今天数字电台的情况。
They're still there, they're still on the air. I still like to go out there and hunt around and invariably you can stumble across a station. What's changed is the countries involved. A lot of the action has moved to the east, China, Russia, North Korea. Cuba keeps going on too. And in a way, this sort of mirrors what's happening on shortwave in general with countries no longer using shortwave as a means of communicating their message or propaganda to other countries. So it's still being used and that's it's kind of comforting and also kind of creepy because when I tune across them, you know, it's like the world tilts a little bit You know, it's just a very odd thing to encounter.
它们还在那里，它们还在广播。我仍然喜欢出去四处搜寻，无一例外地你会偶然发现一个电台。改变的是涉及的国家。很多活动已经转移到东方，中国、俄罗斯、朝鲜。古巴也在继续。在某种程度上，这某种程度上反映了短波的一般情况，各国不再使用短波作为向其他国家传达其信息或宣传的手段。所以它仍然在使用，这有点令人欣慰，但也有点令人毛骨悚然，因为当我调到它们时，你知道，这就像世界稍微倾斜了一点，你知道，这是一个非常奇怪的遭遇。
David Gorn's current project is called Short Waveology, which I highly recommend. You can find it online at shortwaveology.net. You can also find it on Facebook and SoundCloud. Why we were putting the show together, we were reminded of an episode I produced back in 2011 episode number 23 of this radio program about one of my favorite websites. So I thought I'd just tack this on the end here for your enjoyment in case you missed it. You'll definitely at the connection. You are listening to 99% Invisible. I am Roman Mars.
大卫·戈伦目前的项目叫做“短波学”（Short Waveology），我强烈推荐。你可以在网上 shortwaveology.net 找到它。你还可以在Facebook和SoundCloud上找到它。在我们制作这个节目的时候，我们想起了我在2011年制作的一集节目，即本广播节目的第23集，关于我最喜欢的网站之一。所以我想我只把这个附在最后供你欣赏，以防你错过它。你一定会明白其中的联系。你正在收听的是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。
My name is Eric Everhart and I'm the creator of the site you are listening to Los Angeles. And you are listening to Chicago, you are listening to New York, you are listening to Montreal, and you are listening to San Francisco. I am in the 21st, 25th Rowley North, Banshee, the North, the 80s, the White pickup truck. With the tailgate down, there's a front of the a dog in the back of the vehicle that has no leaves or color the front of the a dog will fall out or color that brings the dog will fall out.
我的名字是埃里克·埃弗哈特（Eric Everhart），我是你正在收听的网站的创建者：洛杉矶。你正在收听的是芝加哥，你正在收听的是纽约，你正在收听的是蒙特利尔，你正在收听的是旧金山。我在第二十一、第二十五罗利北街，女妖，北边，八十年代，白色皮卡。尾门放下来，车后面有一只狗，它没有皮带或项圈，车前面的狗会掉出来或项圈，带来狗会掉出来。
Last year after the Giants won the World Series, I was out in the streets of San Francisco, checking out all the different celebrations going on. And when I got home, I was looking on Twitter and I saw a lot of people were posting links to what's happening in their neighborhood, people out lighting bonfires, and one thing that kept coming up was, hey, check out the San Francisco police radio on Soma FM. So I started listening to it. It was cool and got bored after a couple minutes and started putting on some of my music in the background. And something about that, there was like a synergy between the police scanner and like the
去年巨人队赢得世界大赛后，我走上旧金山的街头，查看正在进行的各种庆祝活动。当我回到家时，我在Twitter上看到很多人都在发布链接，关于他们邻居那里正在发生的事情，人们在点燃篝火，有一件事不断出现，那就是：“嘿，去Soma FM听听旧金山警察广播吧。”所以我开始听。这很酷，但几分钟后觉得无聊了，开始在后台播放我的一些音乐。关于这一点，警察扫描仪和像
music I was playing that really sounded cool and I wanted to find a way to share that with people so that's where I came up with the idea for this site. And since it came online on March 6, 2011, I've spent what might be considered an anordinate amount of time listening to, you are listening to. Some people think it's peaceful, some people think it's creepy, I think it's mesmerizing, and it's elegance is an its simplicity. So when you load the page, there's a little JavaScript file that pulls in an audio stream from radioreference.com. They provide the police radio audio.
我播放的音乐之间有一种协同作用，听起来真的很酷，我想找到一种方法与人们分享，这就是我这个网站想法的来源。自从它在2011年3月6日上线以来，我花在“你正在收听”（You Are Listening To）上的时间可以说是多得不成比例。有些人认为它很平静，有些人认为它很诡异，我认为它很迷人，它的优雅在于它的简单性。所以当你加载页面时，有一个小的JavaScript文件，它从 radioreference.com 拉取音频流。他们提供警察广播音频。
A playlist from SoundCloud, which is a music sharing site, which has been screened by Eberhart so that the playlist only has these dreamy ambient soundscapes that complement the police scanner audio. And it also loads the background image, which is coming from Flickr. Those are the three main parts, and they're all coming from sites other than my own. And it's all legal and free and only possible because each of the companies
来自SoundCloud的播放列表，这是一个音乐分享网站，经过埃弗哈特的筛选，播放列表只包含这些梦幻般的氛围音景，与警察扫描仪音频相得益彰。它还加载了背景图像，来自Flickr。这是三个主要部分，它们都来自我自己的网站之外的网站。这一切都是合法且免费的，并且只有在每个公司
provide simple web APIs. Deplication programming interface that specifically promote this kind of sharing and mashing up. You can create something new that might not be what the creator intended. The design choice being made by these sites, the thing that you are listening to is exploiting, is a relinquishing of a little bit of the control of their data in order for that data to spread across the web in ways that they never could have imagined. In this way, outside and independent developers like Everhart can act as a kind of R&D department. Radio reference and flicker and soundcloud,
提供简单的网络API时才有可能。具体促进这种分享和混搭的应用程序编程接口。你可以创造一些新的东西，这可能不是创作者所意图的。这些网站所做出的设计选择，你正在收听所利用的东西，是放弃了一点点对其数据的控制，以便这些数据以他们从未想象过的方式在网络上广泛传播。通过这种方式，像埃弗哈特这样外部和独立的开发人员可以充当一种研发部门。无线电参考和Flickr以及SoundCloud，
and the artists offering creative commons, wealthy free music on soundcloud, did not imagine this use of their content. But they do have an API. They just created a shareable architecture that taps into a remixing culture where new ideas can flourish. Since the site is launched and it where gets around,
以及在SoundCloud上提供知识共享、免版税音乐的艺术家们，并没有想象过他们内容的这种使用方式。但他们确实有一个API。他们只是创建了一个可共享的架构，融入了一种新思想可以蓬勃发展的混音文化。自从网站上线并且传开以来，
it's been very popular. I've been contacted by lots and lots of artists from SoundCloud and they all want to be part of it. They all think it's cool and they're asking me, can I have my music included on your site? Now they're not getting anything out of it. They're not getting paid. There's no royalties.
它一直非常受欢迎。我收到了来自SoundCloud的大量艺术家的联系，他们都想成为其中的一部分。他们都觉得这很酷，并问我：“我可以把我的音乐包含在你的网站上吗？”现在他们从中什么也没得到。他们没有得到报酬。没有版税。
There's nothing like that. But they are getting exposure. I think these are people who posted their music up there because they wanted to share it with people, and now they're finding their sharing with a lot more people. So it's kind of like a virtuous cycle, I guess, where I created something, I'm not looking for anything in return, the artists are getting something out of it. Soundcloud and radio reference are getting something out of it because there are more people are becoming aware of their services. So really at zero cost to me
没有类似的东西。但他们正在获得曝光。我认为这些人把他们的音乐发到那里是因为他们想和人们分享，现在他们发现他们正在和更多的人分享。所以这有点像一个良性循环，我猜，我创造了一些东西，我不寻求任何回报，艺术家们从中得到了东西。SoundCloud和无线电参考从中得到了东西，因为有更多的人开始了解他们的服务。所以实际上对我或艺术家们来说成本为零，
or to the artists, we're all building something together that kind of enhances everyone's work. Designing for openness allows others to answer the questions that you don't have the answers to, but it's greatest power maybe that it allows others to ask the questions that you don't have the answers to. But it's greatest power, maybe, that it allows others to ask the questions that you haven't even thought to ask. This is Roman again in 2013. You are listening.to has grown into dozens of pages now, including one that features the number stations actually, and probably the radio chatter of a city near you. These local radio transmissions are passing through your body right now, so you might as 99154 and be in route to Bayford, Mars. 99% invisible is Sam Greenspan, Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio, KALW in San Francisco
我们都在共同构建一些东西，它有点增强了每个人的工作。为开放性设计允许其他人回答你没有答案的问题，但它最大的力量也许在于它允许其他人提出你甚至没有想到要问的问题。我是罗曼，2013年再次。You are listening.to 现在已经发展到几十个页面的规模，其中包括一个实际展示数字电台的页面，以及你附近某个城市的无线电闲聊。这些本地无线电传输现在正穿过你的身体，所以你可能像99154一样在前往贝福德、马斯的路上。99% Invisible 的成员有萨姆·格林斯潘（Sam Greenspan）、艾弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Truffleman）和我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 本地公共广播电台 KALW
and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. We are now produced at a beautiful downtown Oakland, California, the home of radio. Thanks to our friends at the architectural firm Arxine for giving us a place to call home, a place to hang our hats, and a place to hang out with real architects. They are really talented and kind group of people, get to know them at Arxine.com. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. Sam Greenspan tweets at SamListens,
和旧金山美国建筑师学会的项目。我们现在在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心一个美丽的地方制作，那是广播的发源地。感谢我们在建筑事务所 Arxine 的朋友们给我们提供了一个可以称之为家的地方，一个挂帽子的地方，和一个与真正的建筑师交往的地方。他们是一群才华横溢、心地善良的人，在 Arxine.com 上了解他们。你可以在Facebook上找到并喜欢这个节目。我在Twitter上是 @Roman Mars。萨姆·格林斯潘在Twitter上是 @SamListens，
Avery tweets at Troublemen, but we have all kinds of great stuff going on, including links to shortwaveology and you are listening to on our website, it is 999PI.org. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
艾弗里在Twitter上是 @Troublemen，但我们有很多很棒的内容正在进行中，包括我们网站上指向短波学和你正在收听的链接，网址是 999PI.org。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子以发表评论。